-How is everything, by the way,
with the quarantine?
Are you okay?
-You know, I got this --
as soon as it happened,
I bought this tiny little cabin
up in Montana,
and you know, it keeps me
way far away from anybody.
I don't see a human soul,
really, up here.
It's fantastic.
I bought it from
a guy named Kaczynski.
It was kind of a mess
when I got it, but...
No Wi-Fi or cable.
It's like the guy
hated technology.
-Oh, my gosh.
Did you get it fairly cheap,
or is it...?
-Yes, I did.
Yes, I did.
But I'm getting fat.
That's the problem.
Are you getting fat
during this COVID thing?
I'm getting a little fat.
My head never gains weight,
which is fantastic
for this Zoom medium.
-Yeah.
-But, yeah, down here,
I'm starting to, like --
I'm ordering some of those
rocking chairs they sell outside
of Cracker Barrel restaurants.
You know, the extra wide ones.
-[ Laughs ]
-They're almost comedy ones.
You go, "who would sit in that"
-For that big, wide
all-American ass.
You know?
It's great.
And I just go, "More biscuits!
More biscuits!"
I love that place.
-More biscuits.
I love Cracker Barrel
restaurant, man.
It's the greatest.
-"More Biscuits" is the sequel
to "Memoirs and Misinformation."
-"More Biscuits."
That's right.
-"More Biscuits" is the sequel.
Hey, by the way, we were talking
about some of the celebs
that you bring up in the book.
-Yeah.
-Did you get any --
Anyone getting mad at you
for bringing --
You know, like --
-No, I think they're reacting
pretty well.
Like, pretty much like this,
I think.
"Huh?!"
-[ Laughing ]
-"What the hell is this?!
Wha-- What?!
Oh!
What did he --
[ Gasps ]
Oh!
Why, I oughta!"
-[ Laughing ]
There's a lot of that going on.
-Uh-huh.
-Except for Gary Busey,
who's going like this --
"If you wear it on your head
when you're hang-gliding,
it'll blow your mind open
like a lobster dinner."
-The audiobook here
is done by Jeff Daniels,
who, obviously...
-Yes.
-...you worked with,
"Dumb and Dumber."
And I love Jeff Daniels.
He's an amazing actor.
His quote -- [ Laughs ]
He was quoted as saying,
"I had no idea Jim
knew so many big words."
-Yeah, I heard about that.
To that I say,
Pneumonoultramicroscopic-
silicovolcanokoniosis.
Do you know what that word is?
-Pwkk!
No.
-Well, maybe you should call
Jeff and find out if he knows.
-I just know that I'm not gonna
play Scrabble with you.
-It's the biggest word
humanity has ever produced,
and I know it.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God!
-That's all I'm saying.
-You don't have to be
so cocky about it.
-I feel like I had
to defend myself there.
-I wasn't attacking.
-That's right.
A lot of people don't know
that I've reached my apotheosis.
-[ Laughs ]
Jim, what do you hope readers
take away from the book?
-Gosh, uh, I hope they...
they, uh, have a great, great...
great time, honestly.
I want them to have a good time.
I want them to be so struck
by this strangeness
and the invention of this book
that they rip their nipples off
and run into the streets,
screaming my name.
-[ Laughs ]
-And then, when they get hit
by the car, and they lay there,
they can't even remember
their own name,
and that's really all I'm after.
-You're not asking much.
-I want us all to be nameless,
one thing, joined in alchemy.
-Wow.
-I will say,
the last page, which I won't --
[ Laughing ]
The last page --
-God, he's really gotten
out of control with this.
-No, no.
I think you're not even close
to where you belong yet.
-It's fantastic.
And you know what?
It is like a lobster dinner.
It really is.
'Cause once you think you're
full and you've eaten it all,
you'll realize
there's meat in the legs!
-[ Laughing ]
-There's meat in the legs.
And the fantasy continues.
[ Both laugh ]
-How'd you come up
with the cover, by the way?
-Oh, the cover.
The cover is a wild story.
That cover is actually my face
after being told
that I have 10 minutes to live.
And that's for real.
That was a missile test --
Sorry. Not a missile test.
A fake missile alert in Hawaii.
-Yes.
-I was there.
-No!
-I was writing.
My assistant, Linda, called me.
She was crying. She said,
"We have 10 minutes left."
And I said, "What do you mean."
She said, "The missiles
are coming from North Korea."
-I remember this.
They sent out
an emergency text to everybody.
-It was completely real to us.
And I went -- You know,
my brain started winding.
And I tried
to get off the island.
And my daughter --
I couldn't get off the island.
And then,
the question was posed,
"Should we all try
to get together."
I said, "I don't want to die
in my car."
And we had to say goodbye.
And I sat on the lanai
and looked out at the ocean,
and at that point,
I started going,
"Okay. Well, what can I do
with this last moment of time?"
And I just decided to go through
a list of gratitudes,
and honest to God,
I just could not stop thinking
of wonderful things
that have happened to me
and blessings that I've had,
so it was lovely.
It was lovely.
And I got to a point of grace
with about two minutes to spare
when I found out
it wasn't actually happening.
And all I was planning to do was
close my eyes an be thankful,
'cause it's been a good ride.
-What did you do
when you found out
that it was a fake missile test?
-Then I got pissed off,
and heads rolled.
[ Both laugh ]
-"I had a kegger, dude!"
-[ Laughing ]
Exactly!
Yeah.
"I smoked a tree!"
-[ Laughing ]
It is so creative.
It's so fun.
You re-read pages over.
I laughed --
-And there's meat in the legs!
-And there is meat in the legs.
Ladies and gentlemen, that is
the one and only Jim Carrey.
Thank you so much
for coming on our show.
I really appreciate it, buddy.
-So great to see you, man.
-So great to see you.
-And way to go on all of this
and keeping it alive
and keeping the energy flowing
and making people happy.
Congratulations.
-Thank you, buddy.
Thank you so much.